alors jeanne vous êtes dans ce film une
femme qui mêlait à la vie de tous ces
hommes qui s'aiment entre eux vous êtes
la femme de l'un la maîtresse de l'autre
et vous avez une certaine affection pour
le troisième ça doit faire un drôle
d'effet d'être la seule femme sur un
plateau il n'ya que des hommes qui re
les hommes j'aimerais pour prendre pour
ce que vous avez dit tu as l'air parce
que je pense que querelle c'est une
farce bender et pas seulement un film
sur l'homosexualité
c'est un film sur la sexualité c'est à
dire que bon le scénario et est une
adaptation de l'oeuvre d'un poète et
d'un grand écrivain français qui est
jean genet et à partir du moment où il y
a un certain temps une gravité et qu'on
traite de problèmes qui nous concernent
tous
tout d'un coup cela échappe à n'importe
quelle catégorie
oui ce que je veux dire et en plus au
début il y à un commentaire dans le fim
et qui parle de normal donc c'est
quelque chose qui est en dehors d'un
ghetto d'une spécificité
alors il est évident que en tant que
présence féminine
je suis seul je suis seul et je me suis
senti bien puisque pardonnez moi je
sentais que je représentais un symbole
c'est à dire une féminité et qui faisait
rêver ou qui faisait cauchemarder en
tout cas qui étaient obsessionnel toute
façon la femme est toujours présente
dans le monde homosexuel ça peut être la
mère ça peut être la miss a peut-être la
femme idéale et dans les films de
fassbinder elle existe toujours
d'ailleurs il a été marié bien sûr il a
été marié alors donc peut-être qu'on
peut parler de bisexualité
on n'est pas là pour faire de la nature
et en plus rare fassbinder a fait des
films non seulement et sur une
facettes de la sexualité dix ans mais
aussi des critiques sociales très
violente
il est mort avant que ce film ne soient
complètement terminées au montage
c'est donc son dernier film comment avez
vous l avez vous été approché par lui et
comment avez vous vécu cette expérience
qui donc vous ne saviez pas que ça
allait être la dernière de fassbinder
bien j'étais abordé tout simplement non
pas tout simplement d'ailleurs parce que
c'est sa femme son ex femme qui m'a
téléphoné en me disant rhyner aimerait
que je te dise quelque chose il faudrait
beaucoup que tu joues lysiane dans corel
il se trouve que nous avions des
relations communes parce que je connais
à peu près tous les réalisateurs
allemands et en particulier ceux qui
sont très amis avec lui bon ben j'ai
accepté immédiatement jean genet has
been des normales et tourné avec
fassbinder qu'est-ce que ça avait de
différents ou de pareils à d'autres
metteurs en scène
à lire et il y avait quelque chose de
très étonnant c'est que quand je suis
arrivé la première fois sur le plateau
je n'ai pas vu d'habitude quand on va
sur un tournage première personne qu'on
voit c'est le metteur en scène
là non et déjà avant de venir tourner je
l'avais jamais rencontrée mais je
rencontrais ses collaborateurs et c'est
une présence aucune fassbinder et sur le
plateau j'ai mis du temps à découvrir
crj senti un regard sur moi j'ai regardé
c'est lui il était partout et nulle part
et puis ce qui est très particulier
aussi c'est l'intensité et la fébrilité
du tournage et en plus elle était
exacerbée parce que au lieu de tourner
bon en extérieur mettons en studio dans
des studios différents tous les décors
des films étaient construits sur le même
plateau
ce qui fait que ça allait à une vitesse
extraordinaire et on passait d'un lieu à
un autre d'une façon un peu plus active
que dans la vie réelle on était dans la
rue après c'était une porte
c'était le bateau a précédé le bar a
précédé la chambre en foot l1 lieu 1
comme ça et puis 12 heures 14 heures de
travail par jour et je pense que sa
disparition bon c'est un coup terrible
pour les gens qui étaient très proches
de lui
c'est grave bon le cinéma il était très
important dans l'histoire du cinéma
allemand et danse à sa vivacité dans son
intensité mais c'est un homme qui
faisait travailler énormément de gens y
avait des gens qui étaient tout le temps
sur la brèche à cause de lui parce qu'il
préparait toujours quelque chose
et d'ailleurs quand il est mort il avait
terminé le montage mais il déjà il avait
presque terminé son scénario et
commencer à tourner quinze jours après
quoi vous avez donné envie